[Music]
welcome back to off-the-record we talked
about and today whatever we got a
different crew today
we were gonna do some conspiracy corner
but we wanted to do whatever the [ __ ] we
want shooting the [ __ ] that's right
thank you very much
so last night's Nicky's Packers lost a
championship on a public stage Nicky's
team lost and Nicky synonymous for being
known as as the Packers fan was there a
penalty for that because I know you guys
gamble for your I wish me sexually
gamble yeah you be getting so many
[ __ ] the ends when playoffs start so
like fantasy is already over mmm but I
don't like to make best because then you
know sometimes the spread like the
spread was against the Packers so like
why why would I want beg is my own team
that's true what are we having fun I
only got a pretty cool [ __ ] out of it
so I'm in a nice but that's fine well
why don't you just like purposely fail
so then you can do sexual favors and
stuff that's pretty so that's funny too
yeah but then also would you just ask
for a [ __ ] because they got a thing
for some crazy [ __ ] like what like can I
peg it mmm what like crazy [ __ ] right
like pegging like like something that
they don't want Hey Oh pegging Jesus I
know maybe like something that would've
been funny like you got to like put your
feet up against the wall put one hand
and it's like all they're done some [ __ ]
like upside down yeah exactly why would
I not let my wife do that cuz that's
funny
that's fun right side up and then suck
it this is if the Packers lose or win
either
oh you're interesting the bad way yeah
wait
and is it me that's I win I'm gonna get
to humiliate you yeah
I just have a vision and an idea that I
would like to execute based on the
outcome of this game Nelson what's your
deepest darkest sexual kink I can't talk
about like it popped up he knows what it
is - ah man my deepest darkest Oh Nelson
world we're live you're killing air
right now you're killing there's your
Steve I've told you what what about us
I've told you so many times is anyone
willing to talk about their deepest art
[Applause]
he said everything everything said too
much what's the money that people are
most shocked by what sexual fantasy what
aren't you guys shocked by I don't know
what's left well you know what I know
the normal things grosses me out
missionary boo things like Oh what I
love missionary but like the things like
oh I love anal like a lot of guys want
to get it - anal right like that's a big
[ __ ] thing and that's the taboo thing
like all that special [ __ ] that's
special ass I can't do the [ __ ] man
yeah oh come on you could do it okay you
were made come on I did it twice
Steve what if you're at gunpoint dude
I'm like hey you pound that bitch's ass
if I could I'm sorry that would be
stressful if I could you know what's
always sounded interesting to me that I
know Nikki can relate with mm something
in public yeah I thought a very
interesting something that's not it's an
idiot console where you're not supposed
to be where anywhere where you can't not
supposed to be I've done it in a forest
but I'll saw change because for me was
it the thrill of the outside I was just
too [ __ ] horny that I was doing it in
a car outside but I would much rather be
in my house yeah I didn't like it I've
done it one time and I didn't like it at
all cars are really cramped though of
course so I think that's a really nice
idea but there's like there's no way to
put your legs yeah but I think what
people like is the thrill of the I just
need to do it right now yeah for me I
feel like a pervert that can't wait till
I get home yeah so I feel shamed but
I'll
got comfortable I see those couple years
before you get your own place and you're
living with your parents still and you
start [ __ ] agree I feel like it's so
impulsive like you have to have me right
now so like it's I don't know time
that's high it is impulsive but then
there's a whole lot of what the [ __ ] man
I could be doing this [ __ ] you can't
be doing it at home you know exactly if
if you go move back with your parents
you could you could relive that fantasy
that is like really fun when I have to
go to my parents house and they make me
real quiet okay
so I guy once that we had gone out we
had gone out on maybe like I think this
was like the this was like the fourth
date and we went out and he had this
idea of like oh let's go to this park at
night and it's like that same thing
where I'm like I would not have sex with
somebody in a park at night so I did not
think this guy was taking me to the
woods to have sex we have literally gone
out oh do you think he was gonna do I
put marshmallows he made it he told me
it was week on it this is our fourth
date we I remember what he said to lure
me and don't come around
murderuss I know right never front no no
no we got it and so I can't remember how
he phrased I think he said there was
like a pond or something that was out
there I think he just made it sound like
romantic kind of was like oh that's cool
pond and I've known I had known him I
could push you in it after we're done
[ __ ] we're friends her I knew his
friends for like six years and so I I
just I don't know it just didn't feel
weird right and so then he takes me to
this pond and there's like a bench and
it really is romantic it's very pretty
and all this and then he tries to
[ __ ] pee on the bench and I'm like no
sir we will not be doing this from you
what the rom-com - portal yeah and I was
like what the [ __ ] inside was like yo I
was like this seems like there's snakes
here I don't know let's get the [ __ ] out
I'm not down for this I mean what if the
pretty environment was was to pretty
much just set the mood for you yeah
basically [ __ ]
I'm down for it then he takes it then
like we get in the car and he'd like
tries to make a move on me in the Crocs
like uh-huh no sir absolutely not I'm
like now weird so we're more private you
feel comfortable if it's midnight it's
public I was like I'm not getting a sex
offender charge for having sex in public
in a car with new and so at this point
he's just losing
points and he's like alright alright
he's in you know what [ __ ] he's like I'm
gonna take you to my parents house and I
was like okay alright and he lived in a
city that was maybe like 45 minutes away
from where we were so we drive and he
takes me to his parents old house that
nobody lives in anymore
who doesn't have electricity all
murderers has no electricity just has
like a bed and he had like almost like a
mattress yes my god and like when we
pull up it was real dark but like when I
got inside I would say this is a vacant
home and yes again my parents are trying
to sell it and I was like you need to
take me the [ __ ] home okay fine fine
okay you know you're forced beat my
backs against the wall we'll do it in
their storm cellar well have sex in the
wine cellar I like the whole time he's
thinking you're down just not in public
yeah this is creepy oh yeah okay would
it be cute if he went there and then he
lit candles all over the room and nici
out of those three which one would you
[ __ ] him in front of the poets okay yeah
come on immediately if it was my bad
from the beginning yeah something
happened where like I'm being stimulated
like either we're having great
conversation at we're out like a
restaurant or a bar or something or
we're at a pond and the woods and it's
like stimulating and I'm telling you my
favorite and I'm getting turned on I
just wanna go right there right there
not be [ __ ] on a park bench
I won't both have each action will not
be fun no and I won't don't knock it
until you try I'm good I got more give
than you think but if it's all I feel
like those flimsy little wood panels are
gonna break good I got stories misty
doesn't like me talking about I'm
talking about
deep cover ears tell us no I know what
her story thing you don't you don't all
don't worry the husband finds out about
wife's dirty cash
yeah dirty dirty out of respect I will
not but I will say that like when I'm
looking at porn you know like the things
that I get turned on by I would never
want to happen to me in real life like
gang bangs I wouldn't you like the porn
but I like one because it's something
about like the humiliation and
submissiveness but on an extreme level
so I like watching it happen to someone
else but I would not want that happen to
me I would never want a pizza gaiden
[ __ ] open up a pizza box with a dick
outside other pizza guys show up because
they all are delivering with the same
house and now they're inside of me like
literally sometimes it's too cold to
even like get out from the covers so
like why would I want to be bossed
around by eight men telling me what to
do outside of the covers right but like
oh I get turned on by it when I'm like
watching looking at porn just like I get
turned on by watching like the ugliest
oldest dude [ __ ] like a young like when
I see that in real life like I'll go to
Thailand and you see that and I'm like
uh-oh what the [ __ ] yeah but then when I
see that on portal like oh my god it's
so hot horny as [ __ ] it's really morning
I get why it's ahaha nope so back to my
deepest sexual fantasies we do that we
do that quite a bit yes mostly me
forcing you to do things right it's me
like in a sorority and stuff yeah okay
we do things like well like we and we
won't even tell each other what role
play we're gonna do we just like get
into characters and it's usually like he
starts having sex with me and I'm like
no my boyfriend's at this party
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a hostage this is a currency just I
want to leave I'd the cause you guys are
like on set somewhere and you're like in
the words of Carmen you're like babe
actually when we were in a movie
together Steve says this is one of his
first fantasies about me we were on a
movie together and I was a girl like
little tiny boy cut short underwears and
like a like a bra with like a flannel
wrapped around and he's getting his
makeup done while I'm like walking
around set and he's like little tiny
shorts the whole time and he had like a
fantasy about like what if one of my
traps are in a bathroom hillbilly girl
in this fantasy how she looked in the
horror movie it's awful it's called
smiley and we were both in the movie
together my god you guys are in smiley
yeah opening scene they open did you
guys be killed
oh I died in the very first scene oh my
god I would watch that movie before be
together yeah yeah so yeah we worked
together for another year and you had
eyes for her both of our relationships
were crumbling neither of us were
getting any sex in our relationships we
were very horny we would we're so loyal
we would never ever you know flirt yeah
really famous you're in smiliness
what's one is it a famous movie
it's like we did it with Shane back in
the day and my best pal wrote that movie
I just remembered it the logo for it was
really like weird looking and that's
what I remember
yeah yeah yeah do you autograph now
first scene of the movie Oh oh nice a
whole 10-minute cold open all to myself
yes true and your heart is plucking it
work boy I know right was the [ __ ] no
she was hot as [ __ ] in the movie you
like when you want when you watch it oh
really
but right I'm hot as [ __ ] now I'm hot
but you put a light attacker test win
with women when we're accusing your
stuff stay calm just stay as calm as
father [ __ ] body language expert to
examine me this video yeah you know what
you know it's funny so I I saw the okay
so there's this lady that I work with
I've started paying more attention to
body language and when I see a repeated
motion I'll search it so there's this
girl that I work with and like whenever
something Bad's happening I noticed that
she'll do this sometimes like she'll
kind of lean forward and put her hand on
one hip and she always does this when
something bad is going on at work and so
I looked it up and it means that this
position that person is ready for battle
I go to Patricia and know it's offensive
they're ready to attack like that's kind
of what it is into that sass yeah I
noticed that she I got to do this before
I fight yeah she always does that when
she's like getting with like when her
phrases basically so what are you trying
to say she takes a warning time it's
like that and so she's like getting
ready but she say it and do that because
I think I could tell from the words
alone without
have you guys ever picked up on like
little thing signal pick up on like
facial expressions like micro
expressions like all the [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] times so it also is difficult to
decipher because culturally and
everything that everyone expresses
things differently you might receive
information wrong and then read it wrong
there's one so I used to watch this show
that it was called bye to me where they
like talked about micro expressions and
so I got really into it and like reading
it to him and now I can't unsee them
it's the worst like I've done things
we're all say something to somebody and
they'll just go like and then like think
their lip kind of turns for a second and
it goes back and it's supposed to mean
that like they want to say something
like oh I can't remember what that one
means it means something like they
didn't believe what you just said or
like if somebody's like holding their
hand over their mouth like not like the
way you're doing it but like when they
go like this or something it means that
they want to say something but they
can't you know and like I pick up on
that [ __ ] all the time and I hate it I
hope that you're good at it terribly
that nothing when I just don't care
about what the person's talking about so
like all right but you could be wanting
to say okay shut up
I failed Spanish three times in a row
and to this day when I hear certain
Spanish words I'm like I think I know
what they're saying scam this is a scam
it's even worse because I know that it's
not exactly accurate so I'll see it and
I'll be like oh my god is that what no
it's not you don't know you don't know
what it's like but it is it takes time
because it's not one definition for all
there's this one guy who invented cycle
analysis I think that's what it is but
he actually went um paralyzed when he
was a child and he couldn't speak for
like the first five years of his
childhood and so he was stuck on the bed
and he could he was aware but he was
able to listen and in over the years he
realized that humans are speaking two
languages when they communicate one is
the body and what they really mean and
in the the words that they come out like
logically they don't want to hurt
someone's feelings whatever they're
saying things but that's not what they
mean right yeah and then he started
picking up this skill of being able to
just watch what someone
is doing and standing and whatever and
know what they're really feeling yeah
that's what they do in acting we learn
like that's why you do a lot of movement
exercises and when you're doing an
audition you prepare for the emotion to
be in a physical state rather than what
the text is you're representing the
feeling and people read that
subliminally or like subconsciously they
read it the words could be saying I love
you but the character really hates that
person and then it's just like I love
you you know it's just like it could
come off a different way and so if you
just pay attention to the dialogue yeah
humans never never communicate really
what their what they mean on this
superficial level of dialogue there's a
whole ya the subtext is like an ocean
underneath and it usually comes out
seeps out through body language yeah
what does that one acting practice where
you say the same line over and over but
differently like Meisner is that what it
is like in different positions no no
just regular toeing that's actually to
be present yeah but you can convey
emotion through that too but it's like
to be listening and to activate listen
you can also do it to be horny you did
be very morning but I mean if you play a
lot of Poker too it helps yeah cuz you
gotta kind of read your opponent based
on their actions yep bluffing is acting
mm-hmm big time I had a friend that
study abroad in Italy for like a
semester and I guess this dude went up
to her and was like asking her for a day
and she was like thinking about it she's
like oh yeah let me like think about it
right and I guess whatever she was doing
he got hell off I did he was like ah
like and basically like just did this
like where's like [ __ ] you kind of thing
it she was like what the [ __ ] how does
he get there like like what the [ __ ] did
I do right and like so she didn't
realize that like whatever like she was
doing with her hand like when she's like
scratching her face was basically like
[ __ ] off guy like I don't want to date
you know [ __ ] like actually doing that
yeah yeah you don't [ __ ] scratch her
face in Italy or something that I don't
know what country was but if you go over
for it let me think about it
and I'm not sure man maybe I'll go out
with you and do you know when people are
trying to recall something and if
they're visual learners they look up
when they're trying to remember and if
they're audible learners they look to
the side when they're trying to remember
I feel like I always look loser right
now you're right and the people but
people by language experts would accuse
you of lying yeah yeah I think it's like
if you look to the left or you look to
the right but I don't think it yeah I
don't think I've ever looked up thinking
about saffron feel like I haven't really
seen that you never go hmm people don't
notice in JK party mafia people go like
he looked up to the left yeah you know
nothing into account like the situation
that you could be acting out the norm
because like you're nervous because the
situation is different or you're not
with your close friends or family
they're like no I watched a couple
videos about so I think I know one about
this
[Music]